so this is my fifth time here which is
kind of amazing and I was looking back
at all of my slide decks over the last
five years and it's a it's a bit
Groundhog Day asking that they're all
essentially about the same thing except
each year there's like a little bit more
to tell it's like you know it's like
we're actually busy like we write code
we have new ideas we assemble those
ideas into something concrete and four
years ago you know I I felt very
strongly that that we should work to
create some kind of environment for
collaboration that spanned across
different data science communities that
you know the our community the Python
community other communities have worked
very hard to build very nice tools that
have made us all a lot more productive
but there's very little
cross-pollination of of code and in part
what what has been driving that is the
lack of anything meaningful to
collaborate on so when you look inside
you know what's inside our what's inside
Python it's all different and
incompatible so we need to create some
kind of a compatible technology that we
can use in all of the places so that's
how this all came about so about a year
ago I partnered with our studio to found
Ursa Labs which is a not-for-profit
organization we are building shared you
know portable computational libraries
for data science it's focused on the
Apache aero project I've been you know
building the building the team and
fundraising over the last over the last
year and that's that's all been been
going really well
so our studio has been really gracious
not only to hire me but but also to to
help with the the HR and administration
of the organization so that I can spend
my time writing code and less time
worrying about you know payroll and
healthcare benefits because you know
healthcare benefits is something we have
to you have to worry about when you have
a company so we have a couple of you
know really great you know big sponsors
into Sigma and NVIDIA who have
respectively done a lot for the eros
ecosystem over the last couple of years
and work
a number of partnerships that I'll
hopefully will add to this slide and you
know if I get invited but invite invited
back and this talk isn't you know it
gets more and more technical as the
years go by so maybe Jarrod will invite
me back like five years is enough Wes
but so you know we we wanted to pursue
something different with this
organization so rather than engaging in
contract work where you know I think
often open-source developers will do
sort of work for hire arrangements for
different companies where it's like you
know we give you this money you build
this feature as soon as that feature is
done you know we're out you know we're
not you know we're not involved anymore
but I think what's what gets missed in
that process is a lot of the unseen
labor and open source around maintenance
community development and all of the
little things that fall through the
cracks and so we wanted to find people
to sponsor this work who were really
committed to the vision of the project
and who also want to be contributing
code and helping helping the project
grow and so far that's been so far
that's been going really well so we
founded this he's kind of the
abbreviated background so throughout
2015 so I worked with a bunch of people
out on the west coast mostly in the in
the big data ecosystem too to put
together this this open source project
and easy and the idea was that we wanted
to create a column-oriented
essentially data frame format that we
could use in many different types of
systems so we could use them in java
applications that are more traditional
SPARC Hadoop things that are
traditionally incompatible with with
Python and are but but would also be
suitable in the data science languages
so it would be fast for analytics it
could be used for moving data very
quickly between different runtime
environments so we could very seamlessly
transition from like a big distributed
database to a single node you know
laptop running running Python Python and
R so the project started small just to
see if we could even get you know dozens
of people around the world working on
different open-source projects to agree
on you know the exact bite and bit
layout of what is you know what is a
table in memory
like that alone was a very difficult
process you might imagine but since then
we've been expanding the project into
kind of a project of projects where
we're now calling it a development
platform where we have libraries across
many languages that help with creating
data processing applications and for me
the most important thing is that there's
been all of this technological you know
technology innovation that's happened in
the analytic database world around
performance and scalability for
analytics and almost none of that has
made its way into the hands of data
scientists so if you look at the
database literature like what's going on
inside you know column databases like
red shift click house bigquery and paula
jeremy oh presto you know I keep Nate
know there's like all these database
systems but if you look internally
there's all this like high-end systems
work and just-in-time compilation and we
have like you know and we have pandas we
have deep wire and it's great but it
could be a lot better so working with
the database community is is one of the
big goals of this project so you know
simplified view incompatible data
formats we lose a lot of time in
productivity serializing a converting
data between systems we'd like to have a
common format that if two systems use
arrow they can move data around
gracefully and not have all this
conversion so the project is divided
into two kind of two pieces so the first
is a set of specification documents for
what is a table and the second is a
large group of libraries which now
include a total of 11 programming
languages I got to add MATLAB I don't
know why I missed it I'm sorry
MATLAB now at lab the MATLAB folks have
actually been really great and have made
some some nice contributions to the
project I've been focused on the C++
project so we're gonna go all C+ C++
from from here on in so the way that the
project is is architected in the way
that we think about the world and is
we've we've first focused on building
you know what I call liquid the core
data platform of how we handle and
manipulate tabular data in memory how we
manage like how we manage memory how we
move it around how we serialize it like
if somebody sends us a bunch of data
like how do I interpret
that data as being as being a data frame
and we're building three pretty big
components that they interact with that
core data platform so I will tell you
more about those so the first is a data
sets framework so that's about I have a
slide about it so why don't I just wait
and I'll tell you so core platform the
tabular format memory management we have
a binary protocol for sending data
around we do we deal with memory mapping
so very quickly in about 60 seconds or
less I'm going to show you why we might
care about this so here's one of my
favorite data sets to analyze' the 2012
FEC election donation data set and I
like analyzing this this data set from
the US presidential election in 2012
because it reminds me of this very
innocent time seven years ago and like
the big controversies of where when Mitt
Romney said the corporations are people
you know just it was an innocent time so
so I'm going to read that data set do a
little data munging convert it from
pandas to arrow format so now we have
the arrow schema it has a bunch of
metadata so that we can go round trip to
pandas and fix like pandas indexes and
weird stuff in pandas and so arrow tells
us that we have allocated about 150
megabytes in memory and now what I'm
going to do is write 50 copies of that
table in a stream in a file so basically
I'm laying out 50 copies of the file
end-to-end in the arrow format in a file
and so that's done so now I've got a
little over eight gigabyte file in in
that directory and so now for the party
trick I'm gonna restart my Jupiter
kernel so now I have no data in memory
at all so zero allocated bytes and now
I'm gonna memory map the file and read
it into memory it has 50 chunks and I
can you know compute an analytic on some
column in the data set and it runs
pretty much instantaneously so if you
work with large data sets and you have
limited Ram this stuff is really
Orton to get right and we've we've
invested a lot of energy in laying a
proper foundation that we can build on
for the next you know decade and beyond
of course to have this this data
platform and to not be able to get data
in and out isn't very useful so so one
of our major initiatives over the next
year or so is building out a
comprehensive data sets framework for
interacting with very large data sets
that consist of multiple files and you
don't always always have data on your
laptop so sometimes you do but it may
live in a number of distributed and
remote file systems so we need to
support all of those and data stored and
many different shouldn't just not move
the mouse but data stored and many
different file formats so I've been one
of the lead developers on a C++
implementation of park' which has become
a really popular store data warehousing
format for analytical data sets we've
developed a multi-threaded CSV reader
that's all in C++ multi-threaded JSON
reader we have an adapter to Apache orc
which is a essentially a competitor or
an alternative to park' for columnar
storage so at at a high level like we
want you to be able to read and write
your data sets in it wherever they are
and whatever their format went and
whatever format they're stored as fast
as possible and also we want whenever
you're doing an analysis that the
framework can isn't is smart enough to
only read the parts of the data set that
you need to perform your query so if
you're using deep liar
then deep liar can send its filters down
into the the data sets layer to exclude
files from from being deserialized
so on top of this we're also developing
a kind of single node multi-threaded
query engine that can be embedded in
Python and our applications and many
different places and the goal is to be
able to execute you know kind of the
equivalent of sequel and deep layer
style queries so where query is sort of
a loose term you know the stuff that you
write when you're using data table or
using deep liar if you express that in a
syntax tree and then send it into the
query engine then we can evaluate that
another cool thing that we're that we're
building is a framework called flight
which is a messaging
framework for building distributed
applications and so if you've ever
interacted with a database and I'm
imagine that most people in this room
have it's usually pretty slow to get
data through a network connection and we
wanted to have essentially you know one
of the fastest solutions for moving
large data sets around in a network
we're building on top of Google's G RPC
library and by avoiding unnecessary
serialization on the receiver side and
doing as little work as possible on the
server side you know without taking an
account the cost of moving bytes through
kind of through your network so
depending on how fast your network is
like just on my laptop from client to
server I'm able to move about three
gigabytes per second which you know
compared to other protocols removing
data is pretty remarkable so let's talk
about our so luckily this has all been
about C++ but R has this really great
thing called our CPP and one of my
colleagues is for man Francois who is
one of the core developers of our CPP so
we've got great expertise to develop
really high quality useable bindings to
these libraries that can be used in our
to build analytics and data toolkits for
our so we've started doing that it's a
subtree within within the apache aero
codebase and we want to basically expose
as much of the functionality that we're
building in the core libraries so that
package developers in AR can use those
tools to build faster and more
interoperable data processing tools in R
so one question that people often have
is how is power
aero data frames or Aero tables
different from our data frames the short
story is that the concept of null or the
concept of Na are represented by bits
instead of special values and that's
partly because we have so many data
types that it would be really onerous to
define all these different conventions
for storing nulls so we have a single
way that we represent nulls and all
types the way that we deal with strings
is a lot more efficient for analytics
because every string and a column is
right next to the previous one so
there's no like
cache misses when you're looking up data
and DRAM the data is chunked so if you
saw in my demo like I had fit a large 8
gigabyte data set that was in 50 pieces
so I don't have to read all the pieces
and then go through an expensive what's
the word H stack or it's like some R
function that does like concatenates
data frames you don't have to do that
because the assumption is the data is
chunked it may be streaming so you don't
have to convert it to a contiguous
contiguous forum we also support a wider
variety of data types including nested
types so if you have lists of things or
dictionaries of things so essentially
the the algebra of json we can represent
that natively and all in a form that's
efficient for for analytics so so the
things that I'm really excited about for
the for the our community so one big
thing is being able to memory map and
interact with extremely big data frames
this is not new functionality so if
you're familiar with xdf from from from
Revo R that's you know some some there's
a number of our packages both
proprietary and open source from memory
mapping large large data frames but this
is something that is not our specific
can be used sort of by anyone who's
using these libraries we wanted it to be
able to accelerate deep liar and you
know other libraries that would want to
use the use the software to be able to
run queries directly against large
datasets on disk we want to make it
easier for you to interact with exotic
file formats like like parque and not
have to create a custom implementation
that's only used in r and have to
maintain that because it's quite
difficult to build and maintain and
there's some other other fun things so
one thing that's not on here that that
we that we did is we over the last
couple of years so initially my
colleagues and I and some folks at IBM
did a narrow integration inside Apache
spark for accelerating Python on spark
but we kind of left the our folks out of
out of the fun that has since been
remedied and so xavier and roman
worked on accelerating our on on spark
through sparkly our and in copying data
out of spark and our they were able to
make it about think about sixteen times
faster so this is the art the arrow data
this is the original sparkly our version
in executing our functions against spark
data frames were able to make it about
40 times 40 times faster so so in terms
of productivity and interactivity you
know this sort of making data more
efficient moving between systems really
makes a big impact in your ability to
get in your ability to get stuff done
another question I get a lot is what
about feather so three years ago Hadley
and I had just created the feather
format and this was a quick experiment
or a prototype to use the arrow format
to define an interoperable storage layer
for data frames so we haven't done that
much development on the project over the
last three years and the goal is to
replace the internals of the current
feather format with the official you
know hardened and stable arrow binary
protocol and quill still call it feather
but basically it will get faster and
faster as we keep making improvements to
the to the core to the core libraries so
with my last 90 seconds I want to talk
about deep liar so if you use deep liar
essentially you're already familiar with
and using a domain-specific language for
writing queries so you select filter
group by aggregate you join so what our
goal is to do is to take a deep liar
expression which is already a none
evaluated s expression in our to have
the input be a narrow data set so it
need not be in memory as in our data
frame we can take all of the deep liar
verbs and translate those to the
equivalent operators in Aero land and we
can even do fun things like take the the
expressions inside the deep inside the
deep liar operators and compile those
just in time with LLVM to make even
faster versions of them and not have to
run them through an interpreter so this
is a you know obviously a big project
but this is where we're headed and
I'll be excited to you know show more
stuff but you're from now if I get
invited back so thanks for thanks for
having me